I'm gonna start talking and hopefully
things can be sorted out during their
first few you know 10 20 minutes of
lecturing this screen is about to go
away I'll put all of that content
into this nice get her Chow which I am
not logged into this machine course
oh man that is bad
who
okay so while that's happening so I have
downloaded the depository and I have
this directory here I can look at the
readme to get the instructions on how to
set everything up I'm going to install
some packages I'm going to activate this
particular content environment and I'm
in the Jupiter notebook add that great
okay at that point I have a single
notebook and the rest of the tour will
be in this one notebook
so about skipper so skipper works at
civis analytics he's also pretty active
in the open-source community people may
have sort of seen the name JC bull this
Cooper Seybold we're some lots of things
including including stats models it see
me talk about desk tasks is a library
for parallel computing and Python
- does many things this particular
history materials go into desks sort of
big data collections
- bag a desk array and add a static
frame which are large parallel versions
of Lists numpy arrays and pandas data
frames there is some sample data in here
or just round 15 megabytes and they'll
also a bunch of exercises to go through
some both some toy problems and some
more real problems skippers included
some fun data sets in here that are
actually fairly interesting so you know
high-level we're sort of paralyzed numpy
and pandas and Python lists with this
sort of lightweight Python library I
understood there's lots of information
you go to - hi Dada org when you have
internet you can get lots more
information there's other tutorials
let's sit there there's lots of YouTube
videos learning materials etc so at its
core tasks is a task scheduler which
means that it has lost little Python
functions that all depend on each other
and it runs those Python functions in
parallel that's sort of the core piece
of desk on top of that we've built
parallel rays peril data frames etc this
talk is just going to be just on the
high level just on the parallel arrays
and data frame stuff and not on the core
I'll be giving a talk on Sunday that's
more on the core which is useful in
different situations
I can't thank you I understand Mac I can
what is that Network
as their password
Yeah right just people can't get to the
Gator channel sorry sold six hmm six
like this I'll go try that out right now
okay this screen is about to go okay
there are some thumb drives in the back
the screens about to go away does
someone have that great
there we go great so for the purposes of
this talk there are three collections
there's a large parallel array there's a
large bag where there's kind of like a
spice Park RDD and there's a large data
frame which is a lot like a panda's data
frame these objects produce tasks graphs
which are sort of arbitrary collections
of Python functions they need to run
with dependencies in parallel and then
we can run any of those collections and
variety of schedulers on a single
machine we can use many threads or many
processes or if we want to we can use
attributed scheduler we're going to
first talk about desk array so one desk
array is composed of many small numpy
rays arranged into a grid so this this
these numpy rays can be you know on disk
enlarged hdf5 file they can be on a
cluster on different machines and then
one logical array what is call a lot of
numpy functions on all those numpy
arrays to produce logical results so I
wanted to say some this large array I
would sum all the numpy rays and then
some their enemy get sums that's gray
follows most of the numpy syntax not all
but a fairly full subset so when I play
with task array first is a sort of the
most intuitive also came first and so as
I probably would say import numpy I'd
make a an umpire array of the first 25
numbers for and Oscar ray I could do
that same thing but replacing the numpy
with NP with da for da spray I provide
one more piece of information which is
how I want to break up my large array
here I'm asking to break up that that
large array into chunks of size five so
now five chunks each of size five
so the object that we get out is a desk
array we can do you know normal Python
syntax on that that produces more desk
arrays and if you look at what that did
that produced a computational graph of
functions we have to call or to create
this result so for example if I wanted
to say look at X dot some I would call a
range and a bunch of in pieces and I
would call some on all of those pieces
and I would sum all of those sums so
this is way of visualizing a computation
though that combination is stored
internally as a bunch of sort of delayed
functions this should like like
gobbledygook to you but the very sort of
Technol people might want to look look
at this and see how it's sort of
arranging or representing these
computations and in the end what we have
to care about is actually producing that
result so I can do you know X dot y a
squared dot sum and I can get a result
out fairly quickly so this is a very
small example but it's showing how -
gray is composing normal numpy syntax as
a bunch of small numpy functions
coordinated together so as an exercise a
quick show of hands who is ready to go
with everything right now rate okay
so if you have an accountant installed
you could go to this github repository
and just download this single notebook
and that would have enough information
for you to do the first part of the
class the second part involves some data
that will be inspections which is maybe
like 20 or 30 megabytes and then the
last part is NFS is maybe 50 megabytes
spill could pipeline that a little bit
yeah so there's a question about this
visualize command so this this will only
work if you have the graphviz system
library installed on your computer
so if you're on Windows Mac or Linux
need to install graphviz somehow that's
the graph his tool so like if i'm from
linux which you know I am usually I
would do sudo apt-get graph is
presumably on Mac there's brew and I'm
gonna do is there's an installer you can
click on ok so I'm just gonna do this
first exercise because it's hard to do
without materials so the exercise here
is to create an array that has 25 chunks
that represents the first 2,500 elements
of the first 25 numbers so in numpy I
would do numpy dot a range 2500 and ask
I'm going to switch lump I to task array
and then I want 25 pieces so each piece
is going to be a size 100 so chunks will
be size 100
we can look at that and we can look at
you maybe we'll visualize that just to
verify that we did is reasonable that
looks like roughly 25 calls to arrange
so one call to task or a range is
calling many calls to numpy a range we
look up here at the sort of - graph we
saw that we sort of called numpy array
in John 0 to 5 then on 10 to 5 5 to 10
and on 10 to 15 etc so this is how we're
composing one large combination have any
small ones exercise didn't ask us
actually to take the square root of all
the elements
so we'll kill d8 a square root on X and
then just look at the last element so if
we were to print just this so we gonna
saying make this array take the square
root print out the last element or print
just this I just get this weird desk
array thing I actually want to get the
result to get the result of a desk or a
computation or of any - computation you
have to add a compute at the end and
who's gonna take that lazily executed
graph we've built up and actually
evaluate all those functions in this
case using a thread pool I wanted to get
maybe you know every tenth element I
would have sliced differently
just to be a little bit fun because it's
so let's make an array that's maybe
two-dimensional so this one-dimensional
stuff is really straightforward we know
sort of how to sum up a larger array of
numbers because more interesting if we
look at maybe a two-dimensional array so
here I'm making a 15 by 15 array cut up
into blocks of size 5 by 5 so I've got
sort of 9 blocks arranged in a 3x3 grid
each of those blocks is 5 by 5 and I
might you know visualize this and again
maybe so these nine blocks but we can
start doing some fun things here like
you know summing along one dimension we
charge this is a more interesting
patterns you can do this if you can if
you have an economy you can like walk
into a terminal right now and start
playing with this code does it require
anything so it's it's sort of fun too
and it's informative to look at
different kinds of computations you
might do and what those might look like
sir I'm I'm adding X to its transpose so
make X sort of flipping around that I'm
adding different blocks to each other so
you see is that on the diagonal blocks
add to themselves and off the diagonal
they add to their sort of neighboring
partners we can start to go sort of
crazy here let me do a matrix multiply
we can
I'm going to subtract off a mean let's
you know take the standard deviation of
that so we can build these sort of more
and more complex computations all using
Gasca rain so each of these little
circles is actually just a small number
computation and then when we instead of
calling visualize if we call it said
compute we are sending lots of threads
to run through that graph of
computations execute all those napot
functions be aware of sort of what what
dependencies need to be run before
others and produce for us the results so
this is you know parallel computing is
still using numpy under the hood so
looks like numpy to the user but a sort
of is a way to coordinate lots of number
small numpy rays to act as a large pole
using all the cores of your computer it
also runs well off disk so it'll try to
garbage collect data and RAM fairly
fairly quickly I'm sort of going to like
talk materials I usually give when I'm
just giving a talk if people like are
suddenly ready to do stuff I will switch
back to other things quick show of hands
again who is ready to go that's like 25%
quick show of hands who is ready to go
or is comfortable enough with their
neighbor to work with them so all of the
previous hands should also be up ok
yeah yeah so the question is one of
scheduling backends which is a
conveniently the next section we're
going to talk about those great question
yeah so there's lots of different little
circles in here right there's you know
nine circles available at front and once
you finish one of them some more became
available so question is you know how
did all the threads get assigned to all
those little those little Python
functions the answer was with great care
so vast things very very strongly about
what functions it should run when it
should run them it tries to run
companies let it you know release data
that was in RAM before competitions I'll
let it do more parallelism the future
this interesting problem if you come to
the talk on Sunday we going to talk on
sort of more advanced stuff
you'll see lots of interesting
visualizations on exactly how those
questions are decided ok so this used
threads by default so dasker a tends to
use a local thread pool but you don't
always want to use threads you may be
using Python code that doesn't work well
with threads maybe it holds on to the
Gil so you want to use processes instead
there's a big question of whether you
with spreads or prophecies or you may
have a cluster of computers you want to
use rather than as your local laptop you
may have 100 machines any one or this
one a larger computation on those
hundred machines so tasks ability to
create these parallel graphs and dowse
its ability to compute these graphs is
separated so for example we have this
computation let's make this fun
computation here let's just call that y
so we can control the scheduler reuse by
this get keyword argument to the compute
method we have a few options the first
option here is actually just that the
default scheduler which actually just
runs in the standard thread for your
interpreter
there's no parallelism here but it does
let you enter into the Python debugger
unless you use normal profiling tools
sometimes it's nice to not use
parallelism and so here we just ran that
same computation but inside my local
thread rather than in parallel or I can
run this with threads and by defaults
we're going to use as many threads or
processes as there are logical cores in
my computer that's completely tunable
but that's my default let's say we had
Python code pure Python code that held
on to the Gil so we didn't sort of
operate well with with Perelman threads
who may have heard of this thing that
Python doesn't work well with with
parallelism is out of a single process
that's definitely not true for an umpire
pendous code but it is true for pure
Python code so if your Python code you
may want to use prophecies instead and
we can do that Vitus by again adding a
different keyword argument to this
compute method there's a distributed
scheduler as well you can select to a
cluster in your institution and it's
very simpler to run the same computation
also on that system there'll be more of
that in parens section of the talk right
after this which doesn't require any
data and there's a cluster set up for
you already so there's no there's no
abandoned issues but you'll have more
time to play with that in the next
tutorial okay
yeah so it's currently 9:00 at 11 at
10:30 there's a separate tutorial that
was spewed to me of it by other people
that will have different materials and
the difference the way of delivering
data so okay so all those companies we
just did we're all quite small they were
you know a little small arrays in this
next section we're gonna make a larger
array of data on our laptop is gonna
make around 4 gigabytes of data random
data in an HD f5 file on my local hard
drive this is gonna take a minute it's
not trivial to write down 4 gigabytes of
data a random data and laptop once we
have this though this looks a lot more
like a reason you might want to use desk
general speaking if your data is small
you should continue using numpy or
pandas or Python lists but if you're not
it is larger and does a fit and RAM or
you want to use many cores that's really
the right place to use to ask this is
producing just a large array of maybe a
billion elements into an hdf5 file hdf5
is a nice way to store numeric data on
disk we're gonna do then everything
about blocked algorithms so we might ask
the question okay how do I I have these
billion numbers on disk how do I add
them up but it's gonna do a simple sum
summation computation that's the
question you might you know reasonably
be faced with that work you have your
large column of data you're asked to
find the mean of this the standard
deviation of it you don't have any
parallel computing tools you just have
Python how do you compute the average of
a large piece of data doesn't fit in
disk so what we can do is we can just
walk through that array and say million
element chunks those we're doing here in
just normal pure Python so this isn't
das this is just a standard Python I'm
gonna walk through this data set we're
in a pull-off a slice of size a million
so the first million then the second
million and the third million cetera
we're gonna compute the sum of that
chunk of data and append it into a list
and then once we're done walking through
that array we're going to give you the
sum of all of those sums so it looks
like I've finished creating my random
data set and loaded up with the age 5pi
library it's great library for reading
hdf5 data you see it's a billion
elements long so this is you know in
conveniently large I can go ahead and I
can you know do this for loop and it
will walk through this this data set
reading chunks of data summing them
pulling them back interesting challenge
would be to think about how you might
compute the mean or the standard
deviation of a data set like this so the
sum is fairly easy but it's a bit harder
sometimes to think about some of these
other more complex computations or maybe
the mean of all of the positive elements
so if you're sort of thinking if you
sort of want to do some work or any data
to play with something you think about
how do i how do i compute the average of
all the positive elements using this
sort of way of walking through a large
data set with tasks tasks will do it for
you that's sort of the things - does but
it's it's educational to try to do it
yourself to see the sort of problems
that are lives so we do the exact same
thing that was in this cell we can do it
here we are we have this hdf5 data set
we're going to wrap a task array around
that with this task a readout from array
function and we need to give it the size
of chunk that we want to operate with so
look at this e hdf5 file consider it in
million length chunks and that happens
immediately because we haven't done any
work but now we have this nice non-pilot
abstraction over this hdf5 file that we
can do all this computation with so we
can for example compute the mean that
didn't do anything because again it's
just producing a lazily evaluated graph
we actually want to compute the result
we need to call this compute method at
the end now this is actually doing of
this work it's pulling off different
chunks that hdf5 file it's competing
their sums it's computing more songs and
we get
our answer vapid and parallel is very
mindful of for him if we just want a
little bit of data dance is also quite
smart and just doing a little bit of
work so it's because it sort of is lazy
it can do these things in a more
intelligent way okay
this is actually an exercise I'm not
going to talk through this one so use
the task or a random normal function
this looks just like the numpy ran out
normal function except that it takes an
extra chunk argument to make a 20,000 by
20,000 array of values distributed with
mean 10 and standard deviation point 1
the random normal docstring is fairly
good it'll tell you how to do these
things so da dot random dot normal so
loke is mean scale a standard deviation
need to provide a size and also a chunks
so you're asked to provide to break up
your 20,000 by 20,000 array into chunks
of size thousand by thousand then you
take the mean of every hundred element
along access to zero or do whatever you
want there's lots of things you can do
after that we're going to compare
performance with task array and dump eye
and see they're actually getting some
parallelism ok imma stop talking for a
while there any general questions about
what I've just gone over I encourage
people who don't have things set up to
find a friend
the hands are relatively uniformly
distributed across the room so yeah at
least sort of meet a friend and see if
you can look around and look over their
shoulder pair programming is an
excellent way to learn ok
I'll walk around for a while
people seem to have having people seem
to be having an OK times it's fun
adventure everyone so I'm gonna blow
through a couple things just so we can
get to some of the exercises that have
some actual data which i think will be
fun
i'm copying some USB stick that's new
great so they're also solutions here if
you want them so here you know we're
creating a random normal array breaking
it into chunks
and then computing the mean will cross
an axis and then taking every hundredth
element if you know numpy syntax it
should look pretty familiar to you that
ran really quickly I didn't actually
compute anything it just produced for us
some one of these graphs we want to
compute it we can call compute that's
actually going to create lots of numpy
raised OOP there means computer behind
earth element etc that use all of our
cores and it ran in small Ram there's
some nice Diagnostics now let's skip
that for a moment now let's do this so
we can do this with numpy as well but
numpy who has a couple of hindrances one
it's gonna run inside of one thread so
it's gonna be fairly slow i'm ii
actually we can only do this if we have
around 4 gigabytes of ram on our machine
and I hope this machine does otherwise
problems that run around 16 seconds and
task array I can do that that fast Erick
is able to do all of the random number
generation in parallel which is the
current bottleneck in this competition
so randon about three seconds what's
sort of nice actually you can see so das
has some nice Diagnostics like this
progress bar and also has the nice
diagnosis to second show you all the
tasks that were run over time so here
we're seeing my eight cores and what
they're working on and you know they
were doing roughly 400 pieces over these
three seconds we also see CPU and memory
use over the same time and something
interesting to note is that the memory
use this blue line never actually
exceeds around 100 megabytes so whereas
the numpy version needed to sort of
store the entire four gigabyte Empire
rate in RAM at once - Korea is able to
sort of process all this data on the fly
and and garbage collect fairly
aggressively so I really like this
progress bar I find it really useful for
to sort of guess the things of feedback
so I'm going to
just pace so I'm just gonna run that all
the time and now I never do any desk
computation like this one
I'll have that nice progress bar giving
me feedback of when I should expect
things to finish so it's a nice little
tip okay douse krita's lots of things it
doesn't do some other things
there's desk bag I think I've been a
skip task bag in the interest of time
there's question in the back great how's
this is this better
how's this is this better
excellent thank you for speaking up
how's this not better yeah
test one two check check one two
excellent I just won't move my neck so I
can't see you guys then
okay - bag is good for handling JSON
like data there's a really cool data set
here which is a lot of inspection of
restaurants and so we have all this gzip
JSON data and we can look at some of
this data and it sought us this text
it's much more fun if we map JSON loads
onto it and we can see here's one
particular record inside of this big
pile of gzip JSON and it's you know
showing us some sort of violation of
some restaurant looks like the
restaurant is early childhood academic
Academy in public charter school they
had you know some violations they you
know weren't able to demonstrate some
knowledge so if you're sort of familiar
with you know high spark or you know PI
tools the sort of API should look
familiar to you and ask bag it has lots
of you know JSON types of computations
it's very good for sort of the first run
of
prep and cleaning it runs by default and
multiprocessing scheduler because a lot
of it tends to be Python heavy I'm going
to totally skip this section to move on
to data frames which tend to be a
mortgaging topic we have around 30
minutes left
as we're wondering to those but it's
really fun data set some fun exercises
in here I recommend do you play with it
sort of in your own time already be
doing other tutorials because yeah
that's great ok so moving right along
ok so task data frames are let's get
this data so just as numpy was comprised
this is one das Garre was comprised of
many numpy rates one data frame is you
know composed of many pandas data frames
those data frames are separated by an
index so for example we might have a lot
of data sorted by time might have one
pen is out of frame for January one for
March one for February one for April and
one data frame will logically sort of
coordinate all this in the sense that my
audio is going in and out again is that
true
how's the audio from here yeah
check one two no not gonna even get any
of them back
yeah okay I throw that for a bit obey
this stone your type yeah so - data
frame implements check check one two
no check one two
no better maybe we'll try us a bit more
if it fails again we'll trash it okay
that's not very good at anything sort of
apparently parallel like filtering
things it's very good for aggregations
like finding a number of unique elements
it's also very good for anything we do
cleverly so that our group by
aggregations lot of joins group I apply
computations things I tend to give that
slower is we need to do things that
require sorting or moving data between
lots of the different pettit data frames
but similarly it runs in parallel it can
run off disk it's commonly used so the
interact with you know 100 gigabytes to
CSV data on your laptop in the next
tutorial we'll also be playing with on a
cluster where I can do you know some big
data things so here I have this pile of
COC files that represent I think I think
the some are the UK and this is where
skip would be a lot more information
somewhere the UK they measured what
people ate and bought food wise for from
1974 to 19 2000
so some relevant columns this ste or
column is the year and this min FD
column which is some identifier of some
food category so this data frame is
composed of 27 different CSV files and
different partitions so our partition is
one of these sort of blocks of the data
frame inside that's a single pandas out
of frame but I see a partition I mean
something like this one panda's data
frame might be living on disk or dürfen
computer but is one of the components of
our large diaphragm
so by default we don't really know how
our data set is organized because of CSV
files we happen to know that this this
sty our column is a special index and so
we're going to sell it okay this
particular column is in earnest and now
we have nine divisions and it's where
we've sort of told that our frame that
our data set is indeed divided by year
there's one year for every CSV file
that's an error data say that sort of
nicely organized by year here that prep
just gonna make a lot of other things
nicer for us for example we can quickly
go ahead and access say the data for the
year 2000 that's not a frame now knows
exactly into which CSV file to go to
pick out a particular data set for this
particular particular range of data
we're gonna switch out lights check
check one to the back okay no okay we
okay like this no we're okay if it's
more um maybe it's just a reception
issue how are you doing now okay great
my guess is just that the the receptor
isn't visible if it's in my pocket okay
so again we have this large with a pile
of CSV files and that pile of CSV files
is being arranged into many pandas data
frames we're gonna lazily load up when
we need them we have one large data
frame is going to load all of them if we
need to
so for example I can compute the length
of my data frame that's actually loading
through all of my CSV files calling the
length and all the individual files
adding up those lengths let me see
there's roughly eight million rows in
this data set it's not huge but yeah
this could be larger to be fine so we
have some questions we can use sort of
normal pandas syntax show of hands who
here is comfortable with pandas great
that's seventy eighty percent of the
room
so hopefully this code looks familiar to
you we're gonna group by this min FD
column we're an account the number of
elements we're gonna find the ten
largest ones and compute that so we can
do that and you know - I don't have to
go on read all the different CSV files
and it produces for us this result so
just like task array gave us numpy
syntax on lots of numpy arrays - data
frame gives us pandas syntax on lots of
pandas data frames functions like dots
out of memory at CSV can sort of allow
us to talk to lots of data on disk and
load it up each time in cases that fit
in ramp
so we saw here that the this most
popular food was this 401 data set
there's a second piece of data in your
data set this food mapping which
contains what all these data sets are so
food for one is liquid milk full price
so the the most frequently occurring
food that Britain's buy is liquid milk
full price so we can sort of join these
two data sets that weekend we can get
some information out ok so so your
exercise is to find the most consumed
food group in 1974 and also the most
consumed food group overall this should
be accommodation code we've seen above
and then a little bit of Panda syntax
you also play with this data so if you
have intuition about how pandas works a
lot of the intuition carries over so I
encourage you guys just to start playing
with Panda syntax through PI various
things tries that you can find some
interesting interesting content it's fun
data set to play with and it's nice to
sort of get full pandas likability over
data set that is you know maybe many CSV
files on disk I'll walk around I think
see good questions yes this this does
require updating desk so pip install das
sure
okay I'm gonna get started again we have
around six minutes so I'm gonna sort of
finish up this exercise and then we're
gonna sort of have some final notes
again so there's gonna be a tutorial
right after this which is on parallel
computing generally thing could be a
small section that Aaron will lead on
task will talk about sort of lots of
other options of parallelism to show how
to think about algorithms in general
which may be a good complement to this
course I'll see the course on task on a
talk on tasks on Sunday
all's materials been a year old so task
has evolved quite a bit in the last year
a lot of new things up there and tasks
use in other ways than just big data
frames and EDD rates so as I sort of see
those things so that's my extra personal
plug I'm just gonna skip down here to
the bottom so there's a nice exercise so
you just not ascend to Britain's have
been consuming food over time you may
have found that they tend to like milk
but interestingly the kind of milk they
like has changed over time so is looking
to a full price there's other liquid
milk full price and then semi or
skimming milks so you can see this shift
and time rather for the 1990s it'll
become more sort of fat conscious those
were too nice to see that sort of data
set come out of this this analysis
that's a result okay I do apologize also
for the bandwidth issues and for the
sort of speakers Fitch
the materials are quite nice I recommend
also going back to the back stuff if you
have time there's some fun datasets to
put some fun problems in there and with
that I think I'm going to finish there's
other any other pressing questions we'll
be around for a while those of the talk
again starting a tutorial again starting
at 10:45 in the same room we'll have a
cluster for you they'll have all the
data on it you'll just click a button to
get a whole environment for you so we
know a set of problems that I might look
might be really smooth so anyway thank
you all for your time
yeah great